derek shelton returning to minnesota
very popular bench coach here lewis
thorpe on the mound getting ready for
his first start of the year paul tucker
gonna lead things off
first pitch is lined to deep left field
and clear the deck a cannonball for cole
tucker
cole tucker gives the pirates a one
nothing lead a line drive bullet over
the left center field wall to greet
louis thorpe and it is one nothing start
the second inning philip evans
and there's a line drive base hit into
left field
for philip evans well one out single
brings up guillermo heredia here's the
3-2 pitch
and a line drive over the head of the
shortstop
adrianza first and second
with one out and now jacob stallings
the left side and threw a base hit joey
cory going to wave the runner home and
evans is going to score stallings the
rbi single makes it 2-0 another instance
of not trying to do too much got the
barrel to the ball squeaked it through
the six hole outstanding pirates with a
two-nothing lead not boosting derek
holland kepler at first one out
swings frank three
two down and that'll bring up jk
[Music]
and one two a swing and a foul tip hung
onto by stallings a strikeout and that's
out number three so holland has struck
out three through two scoreless innings
eric gonzalez and this pitch is
in the air
fairly well hit toward right center
field and off the top of the wall
in right center
and into second base goes eric gonzalez
he drives home guillermo heredia
from second base nearly got it out of
there bulk kept carrying on buxton who
went back to right center hit off the
wall heredia scores its three-nothing
pirates
philip evans
here's the pitch reaching out into
shallow right field drops in front of
kepler
runner going to be waved home cut off
and now the throw to second
is gonna get philip evans but not before
bell scores
on the opposite field single by phillip
evans to make it four nothing nelson
cruz with a runner at second and two
outs
needed jolt and guess who provided it
crews bouncing one between the first
mates and the throw
shot put it to home plate
by heredia
allows crews to gain second base
there's no chance of him getting the
runner and i've
had nice hang time
this ball is hit so soft he had no
chance of throwing him out at home plate
you just got gotta put it in your pocket
but cruz look at as you see him
he never gave up on that play
to kepler
driven hard to center tucker is back and
it sails over his head
crews will score ceno will score and
kepler has hit three rockets
against the lefty derrick holland it's
four to three
kepler showing some emotion right there
he understands that's a big hit he set
himself up to get a good pitch to drive
kep look at that eyes locked in
good swing loaded up now for buckston
2-0 to puxton
the tying run 90 feet away the go-ahead
run at second
to the backstop and high off the
limestone the tying run is scored on a
wild pitch
kepler in from third base that was just
a complete misfire right there spiked it
94 in the dirt chris stratton
flared to left
reynolds coming in and making a great
catch in left field
brian reynolds with a sprawling catch
keeping the game tied
two and two on marwyn gonzalez
here's the pitch
good pitch a swing and a miss a breaking
ball that had some
character to it
first out strikeout of myron gonzalez
here's jake cave 2-2 pitch
swing and a foul tippy struck him out
94. his hand it's still a little bit on
the side
and that creates that run which flattens
out his ball
to right center field hooking toward the
gap
[Music]
and a catch is made both runners will
move up nelson cruz at the plate
see what cruz gets done here
high fly to deep right center field
here's what a walk-off winner looks and
sounds like in 2020.
in the ninth nelson cruz ends it as they
come back from four nothing
to defeat the pirates five to four
you